remember in 2009 when President Obama
was speaking at Notre Dame said this
about the need for civil discourse as
citizens of a vibrant and varied
democracy how do we engage in vigorous
debate how does each of us remain firm
in our principles and fight for what we
consider right without as father John
said demonizing those with just as
strongly held convictions on the other
side I want a nice sentiment but where
is he tonight what does he say about the
threats against the Trump administration
somehow the Dems went from hope and
change to nope and arranged over the
weekend the owner of a Lexington
Virginia eatery probably heard about it
called the red hen there's something
pretty incredible
she asked White House spokeswoman press
secretary Sarah Sanders and her family
to leave the restaurant simply because
she works for Trump well the owner of
the Red Hand Stephanie wilkinson told
The Washington Post I have a business
and I want the business to thrive this
feels like the moment in our democracy
when people have to make uncomfortable
actions and decisions to uphold their
morals so Miss morality walked Sarah
Huckabee outside and told her the red
hand has quote certain standards that I
feel it has to uphold such as honesty
compassion and cooperation and she
invited Huckabee to leave which the
White House press secretary did now
Huckabee returned home with her husband
but the rest of the family went to
another restaurant across the street
well that didn't stop wilkinson or her
crusade to drive conservatives
apparently from establishments even one
she doesn't run in the same town
Governor Mike Huckabee was on my radio
show today there's a part of that story
that has not been told you're gonna be
the first to hear it Sarah and her
husband just went home they they had
sort of had a
for the rest of her family went across
the street to a different restaurant the
owner of the Red Hen as nobody's told
this then followed them across the
street called people and organized a
protest yelling and screaming at them
from outside the other restaurant
publicly shaming conservatives and
targeting them in public it's become the
new tactic of the left it's not enough
to malign them for their beliefs and
positions now they have to be publicly
humiliated including their families and
you bet their small children
incidentally Huckabee's in-laws I love
this are liberals they don't even like
Trump Hollywood is getting in on the
action too actor Seth Rogen he bragged
on TV how he recently embarrassed
speaker Paul Ryan in front of his
children and he said can I have a
picture with you and I look over and his
kids are standing right there
expectantly clearly fans of mine and I
said no way man I couldn't stop and I
said furthermore I see what you're doing
to the country at this moment and I
count the days till you no longer have
one iota of the power that you currently
nice guy I always get him mixed up with
Jonah Hill for some reason if I were
Seth Rogen I'd be trying to keep every
fan I could he's not exactly Chris Pratt
Pratt but I digress by the way even the
Cineplex isn't safe from the bullying
tactics of the left Florida Attorney
General Pam Bondi she attended a showing
of Mister Rogers a documentary which
ironically is all about civility and
kindness
apparently the left-wing mob who
confronted and flicked spit on the
Attorney General Florida didn't get the
memo
Bondy shame on you so that's the video
of Bondi leaving the theater so that's
what they wanted but as she came in she
and her boyfriend were verbally
assaulted and physically threatened in
the concessions line they came up again
just every curse word in the book and
they said to him hey blue eyes come on
aren't you gonna protect her using a lot
of it you know a lot of other words -
aren't you gonna protect what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do and
they're this far from my face one spit
on my head they were trying to create a
fight oh you bet they were and if this
continues somebody's gonna get hurt now
imagine if a few years ago Obama
administration officials are just
run-of-the-mill local Democrats were
harassed and verbally assaulted in that
way there would be calls for the
National Guard to step in but since
conservatives are being targeted all
bets are off all standards are out the
window this is all evolving into a type
of domestic terrorism and it's only
gonna get worse homeland security chief
member Kirsten Nielsen was driven out of
a Mexican restaurant in DC last week by
angry protesters White House senior
adviser Stephen Miller was also
reportedly heckled at a Deek DC eatery
and tonight protesters are reportedly
staked outside of his apartment building
they even staged a protest outside of
Nielsen's home blaring audio of this
child separation at a border facility
these are anarchic organized spectacles
they're no accident each flash protest
is planned out and choreographed is
planned online first again and it's
meant to shame the political opponent to
stoke violence and hatred and maybe even
intimidate people in the future from
getting involved in the Trump
administration at all why would they
want that hassle then at a weekend rally
this is the best congresswoman Maxine
Waters issued her own very soft call to
action we're gonna be talking about that
phrase push back on them in just a
moment we invited MS waters and a number
of Democrats to appear tonight no
surprise they all refused she did find
time to go on MSNBC tonight and Sunday
to share this unifying message and I
want to tell you but these members of
his cabinet who remain and tried to
defend him they're not going to be able
to go to a restaurant they're not going
to be able to stop at a gas station
they're not going to be able to shop at
a department store the people are going
to turn on them they go to protest
they're gonna absolutely harass them
until they decide that they're gonna
tell the president no I can't hang with
you harass them approach them drive them
out push them back so as Maxine Waters
fomenting violence and using your
position as a member of Congress to do
so well frankly I said this today in
radio Paul Ryan should at the very least
to open an ethics inquiry into waters
rhetoric and I think they should move to
censure her she seems to be using her
office to foment or
justify acts of harassment intimidation
that could very well lead to violence
now reactions of outrage from the White
House to Nancy Pelosi forced waters to
the microphone today but if Maxine
Waters thinks a non-apology double-talk
48 hours after her incendiary and an
outrageous statements that she repeated
yesterday the firestorm she has another
thing coming there's no drive them out
harass them get right up in their face
all the things that people take away
from what she said in her very words so
threatening women and children at a
dinner Oh at the movies is civil Maxine
I wonder why she's too afraid to come on
she'll only go on to the softball
interviews on MSNBC maybe she should
come on a show she can't intimidate
let's be clear she knew exactly what she
was saying and she did not apologize for
her comments in the least
the woman has been saying crazy hateful
incendiary things for years and the
difference now is the entire Democratic
Party has drifted into Maxine land I
don't respect him and I don't want to be
involved with it
the American people had better
understand what's going on this is a
bunch of scumbags
[Applause]
[Music]
the left wants to cried targeting people
maliciously attacking them in public for
their beliefs or lifestyles but now
because conservatives are the targets a
new standard is emerged since they
believe Trump's policies are detestable
oh sorry
Nazi like the left believes it's a by
any means necessary scenario so they
attempt to justify their thuggish public
bullying by blaming home Trump of course
should someone who lies constantly and
enables the president's lies be openly
welcomed in society wherever they please
I would say that the polite discourse is
inappropriate when there are babies in
cages now does that mean that we're
gonna be violent no but does that mean
that Sarah Sanders can have a nice quiet
dinner with her family when she is
taking our tax dollars to implement this
policy I don't think so
it wasn't until we had three year olds
in cages that these people could go into
public too bad on that but this
vulgarity that exists represented
primarily right now pushed by the
president but now coerced on either side
of the aisle has made it much worse and
much harder to do anything in this
country Oh spare me for decades
Hollywood and the left have driven any
semblance of decency and civility from
the movie house as well as a lecture
hall they've cheapened everything from
music to fashion but Trump is to blame
for the vulgarity of the culture nice
try our politics are now devoid of
conversation debate ideas the left has
created a political culture where
denomination of demonization of
opponents and boycotts are routine hey
if you can't debate them can't beat them
in a debate try to shut them down
altogether organized chaos is their
favorite tool
yes it's very alinsky it-- but the idea
is not to come to some common
understanding or even win an argument of
course but to destroy political
opponents and you bet attempt to silence
them when Democrats are urging uprisings
online too
I Republican women safe-havens
peace just having a dinner in private in
a public place a moment of enjoyment for
her family they won't allow that
something is deeply wrong now is the
moment for all people right and left to
condemn this uncivil disobedience and
those advocating for it
threatening yelling and harangue
officials in public that's not going to
create positive outcomes or a better
policy even Chuck Schumer said that
today good for him
it will only harden the political divide
in this country and perhaps lead to
violence and any blood spilled remember
what happened a year ago to Steve
Scalise any blood spilled will be on the
hands of Maxine Waters and any Democrats
or never Trump errs condoning tacitly or
explicitly these and Tifa style tactics
of vicious intimidation and we will not
stand for that and that's the angle